[Musique]
le coup d'envoi de la saison estivale
est lancé dans la région niagara
a besoin d'accalmie les touristes sont
finalement en ville
retour qui permet à l'industrie de
redémarrer mais en pleine campagne
électorale provinciale
une autre course ou telle attention je
suis pas un gros fan atiques d'haufor
syrie clément est propriétaire de
restaurant à niagara depuis 2009 dans sa
cuisine les assiettes ont recommencé à
défiler et sa salle à manger reprend vie
mais les cicatrices de la pandémie
demeure on a perdu notre clientèle dans
certains cas on a même perdu nos
employés donc après c'est comme si on
devait tout recommencer mais avec en
plus des dettes parce que quand même on
appris des dettes dans ce coup là face à
l'incertitude la relance économique
thierry vautrât pour les conservateurs
même s'il croit que le gouvernement
foehn en a pas assez fait pour son
industrie il nous offre un lien spécial
c'est vrai mais je sais pour moi que si
je pars un peu plus à gauche je risque
de souffrir beaucoup plus corps
ou châteaux des charmes aussi on se
prépare à une grosse saison avec une
cinquantaine de mariage ou calendrier de
gens voient qu'on va être très très très
occupé cet été s'il ya plus de leur
talent bien sûr un étaient occupés qui
n'effacera pas pour autant les séquelles
de la pandémie
paul andré boesch qui est aussi
exportateurs de vins pense que le
véritable retour à la normale prendra
des années c'est pas du tourisme car cac
a su faire ce serait aussi le les ventes
et les exports de noms de nos verres
préoccupé par la reprise économique paul
andré donnera son vote ou candidat
vedette des conservateurs l'homme
d'affaires boys berne pas besoin ami
personnel depuis
25 ou 30 30 ans
si milieu des affaires penche pour les
conservateurs niagara reste une région
ni ou démocrate en 2018 le npd il ya
remporté trois sièges sur quatre est le
comté du niagara falls vote orange
depuis huit ans
paul goze votera pour le npd et pense
que la plupart de ses voisins feront de
même
[Rires]
l'historique néo démocrates de la région
ne semble toutefois pas découragé les
troupes de doc word la semaine dernière
le premier ministre sortant s'est rendu
dans la région deux fois en deux jours
et deux fois peut compter sur le soutien
de politiciens locaux comme le maire
jim avait appuyé le candidat libéral
mais le maire est convaincu que le vent
a tourné dans sa région il croit que les
conservateurs ont de bonnes chances de
l'emporter
[Musique]
un électorat changeant qui pourrait
pencher d'un côté ou de l'autre le jour
du scrutin de plus orange rouge ou vert
il faudra attendre le 2 juin pour le
savoir et si aucune des radio canada
vient gare